elle a été forte bonjour et merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
visiblement les personnes vaccinées
auront plus de liberté que les personnes
non vaccinées
comment réagit-on à cette déclaration du
gouvernement merkel dans la
problématique qui se pose en allemagne
évidemment est un petit peu la même que
celle que l'on rencontre en france la
question est de savoir comment organiser
les allées venues de la population la
vie courante en allemagne comme en
france à une époque où le nombre de
vaccins c'est beaucoup multiplier ou
désormais même si l'on rencontre ici ou
là et votre sujet de le raconter
quelques difficultés de mise en oeuvre
et bien les vaccins sont disponibles et
la population se vaccine en très large
nombre
ma question est de savoir comment
organiser la vie en commun entre eux les
personnes vaccinées et celles qui ne
sont pas vaccinés dont il est vrai que
en france le législateur a trouvé une
loi de compromis
hier dimanche après une semaine à vivre
de discussion en allemagne
l'organisation des choses est un petit
peu différent dans la mesure où
l'allemagne est une fédération et où les
questions qui sont une question de
police de circulation sont largement des
questions qui sont entre les mains des
länder de sorte que les solutions qui
sont adoptés sont des solutions qui sont
largement laissée au choix des
gouvernements de chacun des laines
fédération avec un gouvernement dans
chaque land avec des compétences
infiniment plus développée et que celle
que l'on connaît en france au niveau
régional au niveau des départements
alors même un test pcr négatifs
pourraient ne plus suffire pour aller au
restaurant au musée ou même au cinéma
pour une personnes non vaccinées ce tour
de vis risque-t-il de provoquer des
tensions au sein de la population
allemande alors détention sans doute un
peu comme il en existe également en
france cela dit ah les structures de
décisions politiques en allemagne sont
assez solides comme elles le sont
également en france un certain nombre de
structures en dehors du parlement vont
se prononcer ce sera le cas également de
la cour constitutionnelle fédérale
allemande qui doit vérifier que
la liberté de chacun est bien respectée
alors en l'occurrence quels sont les
points de vue qui se rencontrent et bien
les personnes qui sont vaccinées d'une
certaine manière elles sont un petit peu
en dehors du jeu puisqu'elle se sont
protégés grâce à la vaccination
comme on le sait il reste une partie de
population qui est un petit peu plus
hésitante face à ce ce mécanisme et qui
parfois est bien de ne pas une confiance
extrême dans la dans l'allée ces
mécanismes de santé publique dans la
médecine officielle
alors la question évidemment il savoir
si l'on peut légitimement imposé le pass
sanitaires et réduire les libertés de
ces personnes on pourrait considérer qu
après tout elle se met en danger elle
même que c'est leur choix et que le
gouvernement ne doit pas intervenir sur
ce sujet la difficulté est évidemment
c'est que les personnes qui sont pas
vaccinés à partir du moment où il
commence à avoir du mal à respirer et
alors d'un seul coup on retrouve une
entière confiance dans la science
médicale et se précipite à l'hôpital
avec les phénomène d'engorgement des
services médicaux que l'on a rencontré
déjà dans les semaines passées et qui
risque évidemment de se produire de
nouveau avec cette quatrième vague qui
s'annonce progressivement elle prendre
le choix personnel de tasses à vacciner
mais faire porter ensuite par la société
le coût des soins qui sont nécessaires
c'est évidemment là que tout se joue et
je crois qu en allemagne comme en france
on considéra que les nouvelles
législations qui ont été mises en place
sont légitimes à cet égard alors vous
parliez de la vaccination c'est
qu'aujourd'hui près de 50% de la
population allemande est entièrement
vacciner cependant le rythme de la
campagne vaccinale a abaissé de 25 % en
une semaine comment est ce que on peut
expliquer justement cette baisse je
crois que là encore le phénomène
vraiment être tout à fait européen si
dans ce cas il faut le concevoir
dans un premier temps la vaccination se
multiplient départ vous savez que nous
avons bien les attentes de la population
en termes de vaccination n'était pas
complètement rencontrées par les vaccins
disponibles
il a fallu que et bien le mécanisme
industriels puissent fournir
suffisamment de vaccins donc c'est ce
qu'il ya
trains pendant un temps la vaccination
ensuite la disponibilité des vaccins et
ça a été un des grands succès l'union
européenne que de le faire parvenir dans
tous les pays de l'union européenne
c'est tout à fait bien déroulé alors
cela au conduit à une augmentation du
taux de vaccination qui était en quelque
sorte un effet d'aubaine après la la les
difficultés d'approvisionnement du début
et donc il est ensuite normal que le les
courbes de vaccination comment ça a
baissé progressivement une fois que ce
cet effet d'aubaine en quelque sorte est
écoulé et ensuite et bien la vaccination
progresse ou l'a dit en allemagne
les allemands on compte un peu plus
vacciner que les français il existe
quelques réticences là encore d'une
partie de la population qui était un peu
hésitante face aux nouveautés mais qui
existent lors de chaque crise ou lors de
chaque modification souvenez-vous
lorsque le pacs a été adoptée en france
nous annonçait la fin de la société et
puis aujourd'hui tout on est arrivé au
pacs je pense qu'avec le vaccin copie
c'est la même chose certaine personne
sont un peu hésitantes face aux
nouveautés
et puis accompagné par le gouvernement
finalement elles se rendront compte très
simplement des bénéfices de cette
technique médical et les choses vont mal
comme c'est le cas en france
merci beaucoup david capy temps d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur de droit public et
président de l'université franco
allemande